[Music]
an alabama prisoner on death row
when asked for his final meal request
just wanted a bottle of sprite what
that's it a bottle like a two-liter
bottle at least no just the regular like
the vending machine size tim he's
catholic gil huh he just didn't want to
have all this like food in his stomach
when he got killed how did he do it
or maybe he's used to just eating
[ __ ] like raccoons and roaches and
stuff that he is like
oh an indulge finally i bet he's like i
don't deserve it i'm [ __ ] an [ __ ]
yeah those sprite commercials are really
good though when they're like playing
basketball and stuff and then something
is just like
so it was like a final brand deal
what do you want to obey your thirst
yeah that's the one obey your thirst i
was looking at [ __ ] polar bears in my
head i was like it's not that one
there's a there's a compilation of uh
photos like so this this guy
got all the last meals of all the death
row uh inmates right
that basically
died because of whatever reason but he
he made the food and made photos of it
yeah and it's pretty [ __ ] crazy the
[ __ ] people like are looking for you
would think it's all like gourmet stuff
but some stuff is just like
comforting food
like a [ __ ] bologna sandwich and lays
potato chips yeah it's just things that
remind them back about like whatever
yeah tomato soup and grilled cheese
would be up there for sure for you
tomato cheese tomato soup i love tomato
soup and grilled cheese that is so bomb
grilled cheese afternoon delight dude
afternoon cold [ __ ] yeah dude it's hard
to um like what if you want something
that your mom made and then they just
make it completely wrong
i don't want nothing my mommy this is
not even the dinner guan i remember
right now
right now at this moment i've been
really liking katsu with like curry on
the side
so if i were to be on death row right
now it'd be katsu with curry i would
imagine you would have chose steak and
things like you eat every [ __ ]
morning or like a lobster roll
oh like a lobster roll
good lobster but then you gotta be like
thoughtful of like how well they're
going to do what you're asking you can
specifically uh prison like a place
right okay i might just tell the guard
give me your phone i'll
let me get the food out yeah
i'll choose it here [ __ ] order this
you want anything sir
remember that one movie where he was
like i want a [ __ ] tomahawk steak
from that restaurant and he ate and just
stabbed that [ __ ] in the neck wait
what movie is that yeah was it nicholas
cage face-off uh was that one movie ah
no no no it's not facebook what you
don't remember are there any other clues
he's like you remember snake eyes um um
the clues you can give us
knock on him training day
don't know in the comments is it law
abiding citizen it's training
law yes i think it's law abiding citizen
is that it was i feel like it was yeah i
think it was law by withdrawal butler
and jamie foxx right i think so yeah and
then he went to um
he's like last he was like last last
dinner
and then it was that it was a famous
steakhouse morton's or something no it
wasn't i don't know if it was the last
dinner but uh he had like pressured them
into like making sure that he got a
steak dinner and then it was a cellmate
or something like that that he took a
[ __ ] knife and he killed the cell
mate oh
spoiler alert anyways what else is uh
what do you guys tell me
is it because he knew the steak was
gonna come with a knife and a fork is
that why like he no he used the t-bone
the the tomahawk bone to [ __ ] oh
did you just start eating this oh that's
cool
bone knife that's sick you just carve it
but see i watch a lot of movies but i
might as well just be as bad as bart
because i don't remember any of
them all the drugs huh oh
as long as we remember training day i
watched all the same movies you guys
what's your last meal what's your last
meal my last meal you're probably gonna
have to have to answer this one day
i know right out of all the people here
oh it depends on the mood lately think
about it have it in the forefront of
your brain i thought i hated sandwiches
but lately lately avocado blt's you hate
sandwiches i used to hate them bro
because i was like their last meal
avocado i'm like why the right now why
the [ __ ]
would i go
to a restaurant and pay for this
peasantry [ __ ] that's what i thought to
myself what about like a hot sandwich
like a pastrami sandwich is probably one
of my favorite hot springs
some of them are good dudes why are you
selling him he already wants the
sandwiches this final meal
you're like what about this sandwich and
he's like yeah i'm already picking this
i'm trying to argue with the jaw the
past
yeah because i hated sandwiches i see
that's i think it hurt his feelings but
yeah i thought that was my old feelings
dude anti-culinary genius stuff oh i see
what you mean you're like i can make
this at home like that exactly but i
started getting into artisan bread see
cause my artisan bread was wonder bread
fancy that's good [ __ ] right but then
i'm starting getting into [ __ ]
sourdough you [ __ ] toast that [ __ ]
you get real butter hannah put me on
real butter in europe they they think
it's not real real butter i can't
believe it's not butter the whole time
well american butter sucks right yeah
he's like did you know that you guys you
don't spray butter
that's not real butter yeah what are you
crazy i grew up on that country croc
margarine dude
it's kind of bomb though and then later
my grandma uses it as a [ __ ] sewing
tool [ __ ] tupperware you know yep you
know what the real question is for you
it's not what your last meal is but what
is your last meal if you could use that
meal to escape death row oh
there you go spaghetti bro like anyone
you tied together if i can
jump out
i probably should pick a better meal
though i'm gonna order [ __ ] crab legs
and start shaking people oh yeah
hey just order like a giant gallon of
water hold it in your mouth and then
right when the electric chair turns on
just spin it yeah
that's a shock everyone in the room but
you still died though you're trying to
you're trying to go before you die i'm
like can i get a big pot of spaghetti
please thank you and that comes and then
i put it on the guard's head
you can make spaghetti work
the spaghetti straggler escapes oh i
think he starts slipping on the
spaghetti
we forgot that was his mo and we [ __ ]
up and gave him spaghetti thank you and
he strangled us all they're like we
forgot that he killed a guy with
spaghetti
here's a really spooky thing is the
whole thing of him asking for a spray at
the end is kind of like a cryptic
uh almost like a clue oh oh what he said
obey your friends i think it is that's
my purpose i would have got chicken
wings and use the [ __ ] wing to unlock
the yeah so this guy is on death row and
the entire time that he's in there um
these lawyers the defense lawyers are
trying to tell um the court that he's
intellectually disabled and he has like
no [ __ ] he's like a one of those like
iq of 60 doesn't understand like who
would ask for sprite you know that is
like the last bit of proof that this guy
was he's so stupid unfit to be like and
he's throwing and he's friends with the
mouse
it's crazy he's the best friends with
the mouse best one's the mouse mickey
mouse he's stupid
you didn't even read about he didn't
research this [ __ ] how the [ __ ] did i
miss him he's reading for the first time
right now best friends with the [ __ ]
mouse yeah so i mean uh this donald duck
he did commit a pretty uh hating crime
though this is lenny from a mice man or
what he killed the guy that was just
like picking him up on the road to give
him a ride that's [ __ ] up man he
robbed him of of his money and then he
shot him in the neck oh so he was
hitchhiking a dude was nice enough to
[ __ ] pick him up and then never
[ __ ] pick up hitchhikers this guy
deserves to get [ __ ] ran over man
i'll pick him up
in my pickup truck so one of the things
that they say
is another clue why he uh
was like too dumb to understand this is
because
in 2018 alabama inmates had the chance
to choose between lethal injection or
nitrogen hypoxia as an execution method
but reeve didn't understand it didn't
fill the form out
but it's just sprite
they're saying he had a chance to choose
a less um painful method of death but he
didn't understand even that what's the
second one how does the second one work
nitrogen hypoxia it's like a lack of
oxygen so you just suffocate so it could
be just gas yeah maybe yeah it's getting
gassed but then he took the um oh you
breathe the harder you breathe pure
nitrogen he took the heart and
surprised your body oxygen kills you so
lethal injection is painful it i think
it can be more uncomfortable if the
nurse sucks and pass the pokey five
times you can't find the vein oh what a
nightmare with this one you're well you
just get like so insanely high and then
you die right yeah that's pretty tight
and then this one you just like like
internally you get really uncomfortable
and then [ __ ] oh it's like fails itself
or this one you're just suffocating but
you don't even know
you know you're just slowly like you
think you're breathing air but it's not
oxygen or like you fall asleep and then
you're you never wake up yeah just black
out he said he had the language
capability of a four-year-old damn they
don't communicate very well yeah no
wonder
it is a dog that can speak yeah but like
so what's your opinion then on people
that apparently have this like um
intellectual disability but can still
rob and kill you that's dangerous that's
dangerous i think it's sad because he
can befriend a mouse but he can't even
befriend a person i know
his [ __ ] extra narrative and that's
what got him imprisoned dude that's not
him where he was today
it's kind of poetic actually but yeah
the um the justice the justice system
there really didn't have any regrets on
what they did they just their quote was
hey after 26 years justice has finally
been served they weren't like he did
shoot again did sprite 26 years yeah
what's there he's obeyed his thirst
that's a great marketing campaign isn't
it i don't know that's what i was
thinking too is that bad publicity stock
goes through the roof i have to start
pushing for like final
the last meal choice i know that's the
beverage of choice so good he had to get
it before his death where you at seven
up i know you're not freaking in death
row nobody ever asked for seven albums
no one i haven't had a seven up in eight
like seven up though you do i'm a fan
yeah remember what you kicked my ass
yeah i just thought it was a fire game
dude if this was still like the late 90s
i feel like a brand a brand partnership
would happen between sprite and death
row records oh that'd be good
that would be really good maybe petco in
there because of the little mouse buddy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you